hey everyone it's sarah with
registernursern.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to measure
the head circumference
of an infant and of course perform hand
hygiene before beginning
to measure head circumference you're
going to need a measuring tape and you
want one that measures in centimeters
now a normal head circumference in an
infant is about 33 to 38 centimeters
and what we want to do is we want to
place the tape measure around the
largest
diameter of the head so to do that we're
going to place a little bit above the
eyebrows
and then we're going to wrap that around
and place it
around the most prominent part at the
back of the head
so let's do that so gently just lift the
head up and put the measuring tape
behind
it and then pull your measuring tape
around
move his head a little bit
and let's see what we get
and his head circumference is about 37
centimeters
okay so that wraps up this video on how
to measure head circumference in an
infant
and be sure to check out the other
videos in this pediatric series